pour l'autorité palestinienne israël
joue la montre pour construire des
colonies avant le départ de donald trump
de la maison blanche
il faut dire que son successeur joe
biden voit d'un mauvais oeil la
construction de ces logements dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés
le président américain élu qui s'est
même engagé à intensifier les efforts en
vue de la création d'un état palestinien
une politique à l'encontre de celle de
donald trump pour l'organisation anti
colonisation la paix maintenant
israël cherche clairement à provoquer
l'administration byden la construction
et les approbations ou en cisjordanie
sont très mauvaises pour israël car elle
empêche qu'on la possibilité d'une
solution à deux états dans un accord de
paix et je pense que ce n'est pas un
hasard si cette annonce arrive
maintenant à la veille du changement de
l'administration aux états unis benjamin
netanyahu veut signifier à joe biden
qu'il va devoir s'occuper des problèmes
israélien s'il veut réussir son mandat à
réchauffer sexy la construction des 780
logements aussi jordanie est pourtant
contraire au droit international
chose que rappelle notamment londres et
l'union européenne
nous appelons le gouvernement israélien
à revenir sur ses décisions et à faire
preuve de responsabilité pour
reconstruire la confiance entre les
parties nécessaires pour aboutir à une
reprise des négociations israélo
palestiniennes
le royaume uni est gravement préoccupée
par la décision du gouvernement
israélien d'approuver la construction de
780 nouvelles colonies dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés
les colonies sont illégales au regard du
droit international et risque de
compromettre la viabilité physique de la
solution des deux états nous demandons
que leur construction à jérusalem est et
ailleurs en cisjordanie cesse
immédiatement
à l'heure actuelle plus de 450 mille
israéliens résident dans des colonies en
cisjordanie un territoire où vivent près
de trois millions de palestiniens depuis
le début de l'occupation par l'armée
israélienne en 1967 la colonisation
s'est poursuivie sous tous les
gouvernements israéliens
mais sous l'impulsion du premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou
et de son allié à washington donald
trump l'expansion des colonies s'est
accéléré